hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember so you don't have to and
welcome to another rendition of wtr AKA
with their wheel this is where we look
at TV shows they're forgotten by some
but remember by others for just how
strange they were and I apologize if I
don't exactly seem like I'm on top of
things I haven't slept in a bit I
haven't shaven or anything like that
it's just that um the character we're
gonna talk about today I've had a few uh
run-ins with yeah so when I heard I was
gonna talk about his live-action series
this week I just want to take the proper
precautions err like is it little on it
as some of you know Teddy Ruxpin was a
disturbing hell spawn of a toy that was
one step away from Skynet watching your
kid it was supposed to be comforting but
it scared the shit out of every parent
who bought it even Robin Williams made
jokes about it you couldn't do cocaine
there's a Teddy Ruxpin doll type of doll
you think that when you fall asleep the
doll wake someone goes you must kill
mommy and daddy
so it only made sense to have this
terrifying teddy Nader seem even more
alive with the live-action show though
to be fair this is only really a pilot
and even then not technically that you
see they want to do a live-action series
based on the stories that your robot was
reading your kids to bed with but when
they shot the first extended episode it
proved to be too expensive so they
eventually turned into an animated
series and this ran as the ABC movie of
the week because wouldn't you want to
look at this before going to sleep if I
think about is that in a strange way you
can see why was so expensive I mean
nothing looks realistic per se but it
does look like the toys literally
started walking giving our therapists
countless hours of employment one of the
reasons is that they get a pretty big
name and effects to do it
Lynette Eklund has practical effects
credits under her belt like Beetlejuice
pee-wee's Playhouse the Jurassic Park
sequels honey a blow of the baby is even
commissioned for some impressive
cosplays so like I said the props and
designs for a kids show and what was
required at least are pretty impressive
but that doesn't mean the show is well
good it starts off in the realm of weird
when horrifying mama bear is singing a
song to baby teddy
I think she's literally holding a Teddy
Ruxpin doll come true did you enjoy your
breaded Goldilocks mine was too cold
it's the
and in case you're wondering no she
serves no purpose to the story
whatsoever we see she has a map and an
amulet but she never does anything with
it and Teddy says no one in his town or
family ever goes on adventures he
doesn't even mention her giving it to
him or anything
illy apps aren't very adventurous at
least they haven't been for many
generations man if I had this shit the
whole time and never utilized it I'd be
pissed
yeah I'll dedicate my life to you you
little bastard I could have been
treasure hunting and making millions but
instead I'm raising your dead ID ass you
better live out my dreams yet the
Monogram its foot we got to 15 years
later where we see Teddy and his
caterpillar friend grubby clearly
caterpillar milk has a lot of growth
hormones how to find themselves that
treasure mentioned earlier you didn't
tell me that adventure ii would be this
hard on my feet though I don't know
Davey but they come across other
rejected mario world characters who try
to eat them up they're going to catch us
bastard Ravi I'm trying I'm trying where
they would get you if they didn't just
stop at the camera
maybe they saw a salesman selling hands
so they can have an activity to do
before going to bed think about it you'd
be pissed off if you were them to let
they come across an old man who saves
them this is your generic bumbling and
fender who's so traditional you could
just call him gimmick you can call me
yay a gimmick these are my kids
pawn and tool but it looks like an evil
villain named twig is also looking for
the treasure as his plan to turn
buttermilk into gold doesn't seem to be
working to actually make gold out of
butter bill I took I can't imagine why
not she seems to be the villain in all
of this but much like the mother he
seems entirely pointless he's always
just off to the side saying oh and
curses like heroes a run in front of him
he doesn't seem to do anything of threat
he is without a doubt the world's worst
shot
hey he's kind of as ineffective as the
Grinch if he shaved and if the voice of
Captain Hook
I've always known he wanted to steal my
formula but the inventor uses an airship
to travel to the treasure while these
beaked testicles voice their disgust Wow
that's he needed they crash into a tree
where a fairy who I swear sounds like
Judy Garland on quaaludes and I suppose
there's no such thing as a big bag of
air stuck in my tree and is it me or is
her knowledge of technological Aviation
pretty damn advanced you do understand
the simple basics of aerodynamics don't
you in order for your airship to move in
any given direction you must apply a
force in an opposite direction such as
in this large manually driven propeller
then you will have to know something
about the effect of wind and various
aspects of navigation cries did you
teach at a community college I know it's
like she flies so she would already know
something about it but then again she
flies why would you need to know
anything about it no maybe this awkward
overly long goodbye scene will make up
for it
please is the ending to return the king
said goodbye faster than this but they
come across Rock biters tutors who
decide to put grubby to work but place
the others in the dungeon what this one
to work are gently oval tool to look dog
true man I know that's a prejudice some
kinda just don't know who's supposed to
be offended or why they're locked up
with a guy named Prince Aaron who is
looking for his kidnapped sister because
naturally a prince would do so on his
own and have no qualified professionals
for the task I've been here for a long
time but they escaped and agreed to help
Aaron find his sister this leads us to a
giant purple monster who wants to help
you say uh princess oh well actually
she's been kidnapped why would anybody
kidnap a princess that's bad I mean from
a storytelling perspective it seems so
tired and cliched hey Timon we're on
another Royal forests bloodline again he
advises them to see the wizard who it
turns out is just a faker using lights
and projecting effects which leads them
to a giant castle where they dress up
like soldiers to save a girl I think we
all know who needs to do some proper
suing you gotta get out more I love the
fact by the way that the wizard lets
everybody in except the purple monster
he doesn't even give a reason you stay
outside the rest of you come in why is
prejudice so bizarrely okay in this
world it's okay he actually loves purple
monsters you can tell by this post
within eating purple monster food tweet
also arrives there is what a
co-inky-dink the treasure is there to
their landing why does it always have to
happen to me the landing
did he just howl like a wolf or did
somebody open the box of cookie krisp Oh
Ygritte
they'll sneak in to try and rescue the
sister and we've been ordered to take
her out of here just to order you to
take her oh and Edie it was yeah Oh
general get up great mass play chess
with him on Tuesdays so what a scene I
still don't really get they connect the
medallion saying only the purest fear it
may find the treasure of knowledge this
leads to a bunch of treasures being
revealed but they instead take these
crystals that each have a word written
on them on the steam bravery French what
to go let's go
alb for any I suppose that going and
what are those things that carrying
those are excellent questions we are
refusing to answer enjoy what we wrote
on our lunch break
of course the treasure disappears for
twig because something about being true
to your bullshit I don't know and they
get back safe the brother and sister go
home grubby does this uncomfortable hand
gesture and we get another overly long
goodbye as they sail to Ronald McDonald
and then the wondrous dream we dream to
night someday just might come true rest
your arm you weird people
so it was about what you'd expect it's
difficult to be hard on it as it's
clearly meant for little little kids and
again for the budget they probably have
the puppets are pretty well done as well
as some of the sets but it is what it is
a good meaning but still creep inducing
show that'll happily haunt your
marijuana high for years to come
but at least now you know it existed
there's probably a fair amount of work
that went into it and it's moving
pictures with sounds you gotta give it
that it's moving pictures with selves
I'm the Nostalgia Critic and I'm going
to leave very quietly
about that there was no danger hell's
building all that up for nothing that's
life
you
coming next week is the review of wild
wild west yeehaw but you can see it now
on your vessels ad free early access
just three dollars a month to see tons
of people's videos early as well as a
bunch of other extra features check it
out and get the early ski hey Doug
Walker here doing the charity shout out
this week we are not doing the round
MacDowell house that's also a good
charity we are doing scholarship America
this charity's mission is to mobilize
America through scholarships and
educational support to make
post-secondary success possible for all
students their vision is to be the
nationally recognized leader in
providing private scholarships and other
financial support to make the completion
of education beyond high school a
reality for everybody they believe that
every student deserves an opportunity to
go to college regardless of their
financial status in 1958 an optometrist
in Fall River Massachusetts had a simple
but profound idea if everyone in his
community gave just one dollar to an
educational fund it would be enough to
help nearly every student in the
community attend college since its
founding scholarship America has
distributed more than three billion
dollars to two million students across
the country through various programs
including Dollars for Scholars dream
keepers and scholarship management
services now in their second
half-century of helping students they
invite you to become a part of their
mission by donating or volunteering you
can see all the great work they do on
their website or you can hear the
stories yourself on their YouTube
channel these are great people that do
great things and everybody deserves a
great education go to their site see the
great work that they do and check them
out